So we use a combination of things.
Over my career I've used
lots of different things,
all the way from itracking to
usability to quantitative analysis.
But I think the most important
thing is to be iterative and
to be in a process of learning.
The worst case scenario you can get
to is what I call the sort of culture
of delivery.
Which is, your whole processes
are aligned to one ship date,
and we redesigned checkout.
Okay, what's the next project?
And we shipped that, that's done.
All right, that's a culture of delivery.
A culture of learning is,
hey, we're going to try this.
Oh, let's see what we can learn
before we actually build it.
Oh, we started to build it.
Let's prototype it, and
make it better and better.
Hey, we launched it.
What happened?
Let's measure.
We should tweak that.
Let's keep measuring.
Let's keep learning.
When you do that then you find
all of these opportunities for
optimization, and for insights,
that you wouldn't have.
If all you're doing is
getting to that launch and
then moving on to the next
launch after that.
So internally here I have
a number of different teams that
look at both sides of the equation.
We do rapid iterative
prototyping up front.
So we'll build a little prototype, we'll
put users through it, and we'll learn,
do they understand our intent.
Can they actually act on what
we're trying to allow them to do?
And then after launch,
we'll go and track the metrics and
sometimes with the metrics you'll see,
oh that's weird.
Why is that going on?
And then the next natural step is
to actually go talk to people.
There's a case study that Expedia
published a long time ago.
Which was fascinating to me
because they had a check out flow,
standard thing, right.
You have booked the trip and
you're going through and they had this
optional field called company,
right above billing information.
And for whatever reason,
people would enter their company, and
then start putting in the address
of their company below company,
which kind of makes sense.
But what happened is,
they would get these billing errors.
Because they put in a billing address
that is not the billing address of
the credit card, instead it's
the company that they work for,
this was an optional field.
So Expedia removed it, and
instantly they got 12 million more
in profit a year overnight just from
dropping this one optional field.
And until you actually see
somebody go through a flow,
how would you ever guess why there's so
many errors?
You have to talk to a couple people and
go, oh they think it's their
company's address that's why we're
getting all these billing errors.
It's not like bad credit cards or
what have you.
So that combination of
the quantitative data,
hm, lots of errors in billing addresses,
and qualitative,
why let's talk to them, really let's
you fix the product and make it work.